so
those are the questions uh we're almost
ending here
i just wanted to play a quick commercial
i played a little bit for you mike
before this show it's 30 seconds right
this commercial thing about not
commuting now is that i can just drink
towards the end of the show it's great
this commercial was from 1986
okay as soon as i saw it this morning as
soon as i saw this morning i'm like mike
needs to see this
this is 1986 remember jordas jeans of
course
oh come on you were you didn't have
those you're a [ __ ]
peasant this is a real commercial okay
this is a real commercial this is not an
snl bit
here we go did you ever see your parents
naked okay so go off to a good start
would you say
how is this helping us sell jeans jeans
[Laughter]
what is this by the way i got to give it
to semper separate pointed out this
looks like a young owen benjamin in this
commercial
oh my god it is a lot loot a lot man
a lot did you ever see your parents
naked jordash basics
i did but it wasn't all that bad why are
they playing
sexy music that's the part wasn't it bad
it should be horrible seeing your
parents naked should never not be
horrifying
right like like even if you're even if
you're like those people are like oh
you're just hung up man it's like no no
you should
if you see naked parents you should be
going oh god i saw my parents
that should scar you for the rest of
your life
so why are they playing sexy music is
what i want to know
is it sexy oh i did but it wasn't all
that bad
i can't even think about mine it's like
they hit a certain age
bam your skin doesn't fit anymore
my parents have never been really nude
well how do you think you got here i
don't know i always thought i just
hatched tell me you just didn't say that
yeah the kid by the way out of all the
people saying
weird stuff what this kid said was the
least weird it was a dumb joke fair
enough
but tell me you didn't just say that no
no tell me you you hey
hey you steered the conversation into
naked parents
hey owen this reminds me of latina
wayne's world when garth brings up the
bugs bunny thing where everyone's like
why did he bring that up
why did you bring that up man you're the
one making this weird dude
hey i got a question for you ladies you
ever sucked your dad's dick
levi's they're just trying to compete
with them
okay we two could play at that game
[ __ ]
this poor guy is getting ripped on and
he's he's he's the least defensive one
in the commercial
1986 commercial hey i got a question for
you anybody here ever eat your mom's
[ __ ]
wrangler jeans we're getting into the
game too
[ __ ] hell oh fubu has one too yo you
ever nut up in your auntie
what what the [ __ ] are you talking about
[Music]
[ __ ] your auntie oh my god
that was perfect oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was i i can't
[Laughter]
oh it hurts oh [ __ ] and really
nude well how do you think you got here
i don't know i always thought i just
hatched
tommy just didn't say that he's the
weird one like you said he [ __ ]
weirdo
hey guys you want to go back to my place
and jerk off the pictures of my parents
[Applause]
jordash [ __ ] your mom and dad
what could i just i just would like the
jeans
please oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]